what do you talk to joe about
first of all we're both grapplers so we
talk a lot about jiu jitsu we talk a lot
about i'm a grappler are you i was on
the wrestling team in high school yeah i
know i know this is a grappler that to
is there only one kind of grappling that
you like yeah there's levels to this
game i think i just talked no no there's
nothing more yeah there's no that's a
surprising fact that you've dropped that
it almost feels like a lie because
you've said that before that you were a
wrestler yeah in high school it doesn't
make sense well it's funny that you say
that because
and i'm going to cause a little
controversy here right
but joe rogan yes one time came to when
he lived in l.a this is years ago he
said you're a liar you've never grappled
yep and i go yes i did you're a [ __ ]
liar no you didn't and at that time i
didn't have any photos to prove it but
if you look at my instagram i have
photos
of you as a young man dressed in a
singlet or what on the wrestling team
if you go to the
[ __ ] sorry if you go to my i'm sorry
if you go to my [ __ ]
high school yep you're right i was on
the wrestling team for three years i'm
not gonna go to your high school so is
there actual photo evidence of you yeah
you know what you're you're being like
rogan right now and i you know me it
really is how do we know it's not
photoshopped can you oh will you be the
judge then dude
okay so this is my brother and me
in high school on the wrestling team
which oh it's you're uh yeah i'm the
bottom that's my brother to the left i
mean yeah to your right oh handsome yeah
i'm not asking
yeah
uh how much you weigh wow at the time i
weighed um i was on the 105 weight
category yeah yeah um but so i was also
on the tennis team what people don't
realize is that i'm very athletic okay
yeah yeah and i resent the fact that
people that think that i'm not because
i'm doughy you're an athlete so uh which
is very surprising to me why that uh so
i was invited to the wedding yeah yeah
i've also been on joe rogan's podcast
he's a big fan of yours i know i love
joe no joe when joe's and i see each
other we hogan stuff we talked i talked
to him today i said i'm talking to you
it's just hilarious so why oh you hug
him he just never
it just hasn't worked out like i don't
like i don't want to go like
hey um
if cause i don't want the rejection so
it's like if i go right hey
can i do it and he goes i don't know man
i'm busy man we got i got a lot i mean
maybe later you know i don't want that
so if you know
if if he said hey are you available
thursday this date fly out do my podcast
i would 100 do it and that hasn't
happened yet
so interesting
why is it interesting i don't know
because you're like i said you're one of
the funniest people in the world that'd
be a great conversation it's just funny
it hasn't happened yet well it's like
this conversation it's like i just
learned how to tell time
yeah
not like i know how to write digital you
showed up on time today no digital i
know how to write digital obviously but
in terms of the hand clock yeah i just
learned that six months ago
uh how to operate a hand clock to read a
can clock hand clock yeah okay not that
i i obviously i'll be able to absorb the
information i just i'm one of those guys
that just refused to learn things if i
just
what did you think it was before
i would look at it and i would try to
sometimes like if i was at a train
station yeah
and i would look at those old clogs yeah
i would look at it and try to guess and
i i kind of go
i think this is the way you know i mean
but like not fully
you know i mean really grass so the way
ancient people looked up at the sun to
try to tell time you looked at a clock
to try to tell time right like for
instance like we don't look at the sun
right so to me it was an obsolete
information to me
you already had digital yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so that's somehow comparable to
you going on the joe rogan and you
because it's like i don't know much
about
podcasting not podcasting i can but in
terms of like the singularity and all
that stuff like i i know what it is you
know i mean when machines gonna be have
consciousness when is that gonna happen
soon are you afraid of robots see if you
were in austin i would show you some
robots oh i'd love to are you afraid of
robots no i love it you love robots oh
yeah yeah in fact i have this
i think to me unless they become hostile
and it becomes like the terminator which
i think could happen right
there'd be a sky net we have to bring it
down whatever but there's definitely
going to be autonomous weapons system so
a lot of the robotics research is
being conducted funded by
the military
wow
you know the military-industrial complex
i know what that is yes yeah so the the
a lot of the cutting-edge research is
done
is funded by
uh dod department of defense darpa and
so on so a lot of the robots will be
used in war but hopefully not most of
consumer robotics will be in the home
i'm just trying to terrify
you